[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the sky new
city Studio
the world's biggest company Apple
reports its second consecutive decline
in quarterly sales
a typical night for the conservatives to
labor of the liberal Democrats make
early gains in England's local elections
pressure on some of America's Regional
Banks amid cause for the U.S government
to step in
better than expected profits for
International Airlines groups the owner
of British Airways and Aer Lingus Plus
I'll give it another account go for it
looks all right it's not bad
a new Hallmark to celebrate the king's
coronation
foreign
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City we're starting this
morning though with the local elections
it's been a tough night for the
conservative party the conservatives
predicted to lose hundreds of seats with
labor winning back voters in both the
North and South of England that have
been gained two for the liberal
Democrats here's the current state of
the parties as you can see uh the
conservatives have lost nine councils
labor gained three and the liberal
Democrats one our political
correspondent Tamara Cohen is in West
Berkshire for us tomorrow I guess the
the Highlight really is that the uh lib
Dems have done much better than anyone
expected
morning Ian yes I think the overall
picture is a pretty bleak night for the
Tories so far we've only had about a
quarter of the results in so there's a
lot more to come but so far we are
seeing a story of Labor games they've
gained councils in Medway which is in
Kent a really shocking result they've
never held that before even under Tony
Blair they've also made games in Stoke
and in Plymouth so we are seeing a labor
recovery in different parts of the
country I think the key question about
this local election is of course are we
seeing the sort of gains from labor that
reflect where they are in the opinion
polls are they about to in the general
election next year former government and
can they form a government with a
majority and so far labor are hopeful
that they are heading towards that and
we'll head towards that later in the day
but yes we are also seeing a really good
result for the liberal Democrats they
actually did quite well four years ago
when these seats were last fought but in
areas like here where I am in Newbury
the conservatives have held the council
here since 2005 but I think both the
live Dems and the Tories I've spoken to
here believe that the live Dems will now
take control of it they only need to
pick up a six seats to do that elsewhere
we've seen much bigger live Dem gains
they've taken the council into reason
Mays Seaton maidenhead and we've seen
some gains from them in some rather
surprising places which will send alarm
bells ringing I think for the
conservatives about some of their south
of England strongholds so there's a long
way to go Michael Thrasher our elections
expert says if the jury is still out
about whether labor will by the end of
today look like they're on course to
have a majority government at the next
general election but certainly if it
appeared to many conservatives as if
Rishi sunak have been steadying the ship
after the turmoil of last year I think
we're seeing so far that that may not be
entirely the case and there really are
some big concerns about
a lot of results to come in particularly
from the Midlands where the
conservatives point out they have made
some gains in areas like Basset law and
Sandwell and this is this red wall of
seats later for the first time in 2019
so we could see more results from there
that are more encouraging but so far it
looks like very slim pickings for the
conservatives and a very good night for
labor and the liberal Democrats okay
thanks Tamara
that was another Torrid session on the
stock market yesterday for some of
America's Regional and mid-tier Banks
Los angeles-based Pat West Bancorp fell
by 51 and phoenix-based Western Alliance
Bank called by 31 of the major fallers
included Salt Lake City Base Zion
Bancorp and dallas-based Comerica Bank
both of which fell by 12 well all this
follows of course the rescues in recent
weeks of three other lenders Signature
Bank Silicon Valley Bank and First
Republic none of which appear to have
come nurse will joining me now is Martin
Arkham weld he's a partner at the Global
Management consultancy Arthur D little
Martin good to see you this morning
um we've had three rescues where
depositors lost no money it clearly
hasn't been enough to calm nerves good
morning Ian yes absolutely so I think if
we look at the depositor side things
have been pretty stable actually and
interestingly none of the deposits are
lost money which is a bit surprising
retail yes we understand why corporate
yes we understand why the discussion
about payrolls you know being paid and
so on but institutional Banks lenders
other Banks depositing money without
with with with banks have also not lost
money and I think that's the big
surprise which should come the depositor
side so why are people yanking their
money out when ostensibly they have
little to fear I think it is just the
general fear you know and it's so easy
nowadays right with a clip of a finger
you just you know change Banks it's on
mobile banking just has changed so much
nowadays so people say why risk it just
go to a safer place the question is is
it really a safer place I guess you
could say it's rational in some ways
given that the three that were rescued
signature Silicon Valley and First
Republic they had deposits of of assets
of 535 billion dollars at the beginning
of the year I mean this has been an
extraordinary turn of events it is
absolutely and what I think is very
interesting is that you know the first
one to basically come into problems had
very specific reasons why right if you
do Tech and Tech is basically getting a
blow and receiving a blow well the bank
this also gets a blow I mean this is a
banker reflection of the of the economy
effectively same you know with a
signature bank if crypto is going
through difficult times well then it's
clear that the bank also go through a
difficult time if they are so related
but we what we see now is that this is
spreading out to banks that are you know
typical I would say Universal Banks yeah
what does this mean we have four
thousands of those small and
medium-sized banks in the US
the FDIC the U.S government agency
protects the first quarter of a million
dollars worth of deposits would it calm
things if that limit were raised well
it's a big discussion obviously uh and I
think you know what the crisis is the
various crisis that we've seen uh
basically show is they do it yeah they
do it anyway they come in at the end of
the day to protect you know depositors
the question is what's the right level
and should it be for free yeah who
should pay for that of course yeah I
mean when analyst yesterday was talking
about there being a sort of uh a
negative feedback loop these share price
declines potentially feeding into more
deposits being taken out which in turn
feeds further share price declines I
mean there's something in that isn't
there absolutely absolutely I think you
know also when we look at the share
price I mean I think the share price
story is only the tip of the iceberg
really I mean not all the banks are
listed so you know what's going on with
the other non-listed Banks so I think a
story that nobody's looking at currently
is the impact on the bonds and the bonds
really make the big difference because
this is where financing comes from so if
cost of refinancing goes up meaningfully
you know the margin of the bank is
basically you know hit absolutely I mean
would it help if banks didn't have to
mark to market the value of a lot of
their assets as frequently as they do I
think it's also a quite a quite a I
think you know a discussion that that
that's that's an evergreen if you want
so I think generally speaking
transparency is a good thing we saw this
in many places you know also with you
know Europe and and in the US you know
going through stress tests and making
sure the marks are where they're
supposed to be but then there are very
special events like you know we were
seeing with with effectively in another
the the the the the the the the bonds
that they invested in right I mean this
is a mark to Market loss it's not a
realized loss you still get back a
hundred yes there is an impact over time
you know because of the interest rate
now going up we all understand that but
that can be spread out over years
effectively yeah exactly so I think it
is not such a burning issue now the
other I mean the other key assets that
these Banks hold of course is their
customer loans I mean it's the
deterioration of the loan book in many
cases enough to justify what we're
seeing well actually currently we still
don't see a major pickup of mpls
um I think you know there is correct
cost of cost of risk is going up yes but
we're also coming from an ultra low
Ultra long period of extremely low cost
of risk and mpls so I think we're to a
certain extent we're going a bit back to
normal yeah but so where does this all
end uh I think you know it's interesting
to compare probably also the US Europe
yeah I think you know you see a lot of
turmoil in the U.S
extremely stable situation effectively
in in Europe still yeah so it probably
also means you know that Europe has done
a pretty good job in you know
regulations and putting all these things
in place stress tests and so on being
much more rigid but still the banking
system has a lot to do because
profitability is a big issue most
business models hasn't been changed
hasn't been really properly changed
there was Cosmetics you know but most
banks do today what they did 10 years
ago yeah Martin one one more thought for
you uh obviously JP Morgan bought the
majority of First Republic last weekend
presumably at some point the likes of
City Bank of America Wells Fargo if we
see more collapses they're gonna have to
get involved I mean the system can't all
just uh be it can't be left to JP Morgan
can it no absolutely so I think it's a
big value in having small and Regional
Banks because they you know are closer
to their clients and banking to a
certain extent is local you got to be
close to your clients all right Martin
we've got to leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you for having me
Apple last night reported its second
consecutive decline in quarterly sales
the world's biggest company reported
sales of 94.8 billion US dollars for the
first three months of the year that was
down three percent on the same period
last year it's only the third time in a
decade that Apple has reported
back-to-back declines in sales and the
first time in four years Apple's profits
meanwhile slipped by 3.4 percent to 24.2
billion US Dollars well the sales
decline came despite a one and a half
percent rise in global iPhone sales and
reflected declines in sales of other
products most notably Max and iPads the
results however were better than
expected and Apple shares have risen by
nearly two and a quarter percent in
after hours trading joining me now from
New York is Dan Ives the managing
director and Senior Equity Analyst at
wedbush Securities Dan good to see you
thanks as ever for joining me so early
in the day your time I mean the iPhone
has obviously done very well here how
worried should shareholders be about the
the overall decline in Top Line Sales
look I think a lot of that's also
because of currency and and if you look
I mean you're seeing actually an uptick
in China and even globally they're
gaining share from Android sorry this is
really almost to flex the muscles moment
for apple and Tim Cook you know in
obviously with a murky Mac or I think
investors are drinking cappuccinos today
after these results
looking at iPhone sales in particular
does this prove definitively that Apple
has put the supply chain issues that
have dog did over recent months behind
it
yeah I mean that sort of works in the
rear view mirror and as we know I mean
that was a big issue for Apple
especially in the December quarter you
know China looks pretty smooth from a
supply chain perspective and demands
holding up and I'd almost call this
Rocket Gibraltar like you know in this
murky macro which continues to be the
theme for big Tech that's almost become
a safety sector especially given what we
see in financials
obviously most of the uh declines were
forecast done with probably the
exception of the Mac I mean they missed
expectations there is how worried should
people be about that
yeah I think that was pretty forecasted
especially post covid I mean yeah
massive pull forward to Mac iPad that
continues to be soft here but the hearts
and lungs and ultimately where investors
are focus on it's iPhone and its
services and there's both right now feel
like they're they're sort of navigating
there's something better than expected
and that's really the focus point for
Tim Cook I mean they're essentially
going on the offensive you're rather
than defensive and you have a 90 billion
dollar buyback in the back pocket which
is why then the stock shows green today
yeah I mean the iPhone obviously is the
the locomotive that pulls everything
along behind it but but it's the
performance in this quarter repeatable
do you think
I do I mean well I think the big number
I think the overarching most important
is 25 of the 1.2 billion iPhones
worldwide have not upgraded in four
years
so that's really the golden star base
and I think that's going to continue
going to this anniversary iPhone 15. you
know as we head into September quarter
and I think that's really the key here
with apple that that's why they're able
to navigate it better than other attack
players because the install base could
be the upgrade cycle and China is
actually shown an uptick that's
different than we saw from Qualcomm sure
share games for Apple that's going to be
key for the streets
now something that a lot of people have
picked up on overnight is uh Tim Cook's
comments about emerging markets and
particularly India it looks like that's
going to be a lot more management focus
in future
yeah they're doubling down on India I
mean Indian today is two three percent
of avenues within that could be 10 next
three to four years I and they obviously
open up their new retail stores there
and this is really them diving to deep
end of the pool in India you start to
put numbers together this could mean the
incremental 10 billion you know per year
as it all plays out
they've got some pretty entrenched
competitors in India though does Apple
have what it takes to to win market
share over there
well especially in the price point I
think especially going from middle class
with their
down to the next general election um Dan
I'm so sorry we're gonna have to cut out
of this I do apologize do bear with us
we're now going to hear from Ed Davey a
liberal Democrat leader
five four three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
fantastic
thank you so much
friends this is a wonderful morning
liberal Democrats making big gains
across the country
we've beaten the conservatives in bath
and in Brentwood in Hertfordshire and in
Hinckley
we're making gains off labor we've
increased our majority in Hull
and we're making huge gains across the
country against the conservatives we're
continuing to make sure the Blue World
tumbles down
[Applause]
and I'm so proud of the result here in
Windsor
[Applause]
yeah and I'm so proud that when Katy
Perry and Lionel Richie
enter Windsor Castle
for the coronation concert on Sunday
they'll be going to a ward that's
represented by three brand new liberal
Democrat counselors
[Music]
really proud of liberal Democrats here
in Windsor main ahead so many people I
could mention I do want to single out
one of our new councilors George
Blundell
22 what an amazing result thank you
but you know there's more to come as
they continue to count the votes across
the country more gains I think for the
liberal Democrats to come
and that's thanks to the hard work of so
many liberal Democrat campaigners across
the country
they've sent a message
the liberal Democrats are the big
winners in this year's local elections
[Applause]
just like we were last year
and just like we were in 2019 when these
seats were last fought
and you know when people have a chance
to vote when they can go into those
polling stations they're choosing to
vote for a liberal Democrat candidate a
liberal Democrat campaigner they know
that we work hard for them that we
listen to their concerns and they will
never take them for granted
the people have sent a huge message
and this is so loud that even someone is
out of touch as Rishi sunak can't ignore
we're fed up of waiting so long for the
basics
waiting for hours for an ambulance
days for a GP appointment months and
even years for a Hospital appointment
Waiting in Vain for the police to turn
up when there's been a breaking
waiting for months for a pothole to be
mended and repaired
waiting for real action to help people
who are struggling with their soaring
energy bills and food prices
and waiting still waiting for those
hospitals that have been promised for
years now
waiting waiting waiting for an end to
the sewage that these companies keep
pouring into our Rivers onto our beaches
and we're waiting for the government to
listen to people
stop taking them for granted
people are waiting for a fair deal
these conservative MPS are out of touch
out of ideas and out of excuses
people are fed up of waiting for a
chance to kick them out we're all Fed Up
of waiting for a general election
[Applause]
and you know I think there's a chance
now
that we can have that general election
within the next year
and I think the message is clear the
time's up for Richie sunac and his
appalling conservative government
[Applause]
the liberal Democrats have shown that we
are the ones working hard in communities
across our country we're the ones to
beat so many conservatives across the
blue wall and Beyond
and I'm determined that the liberal
Democrats keep working don't take people
for granted show our amazing policies
and so my message to my party is a great
night for us but let's go back and work
even harder so we can beat the
conservatives at the next general
election
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go very jubilant uh Ed Davey
they're the leader of the liberal
Democrats will get uh more uh election
updates for you throughout the morning
here on Sky News in the meantime I'm
going to go back to uh Down Eyes we've
been talking about Apple's results Dan
thanks very much for for bearing with us
um put these results for me into context
if you'd be so kind with with what we've
been hearing from all the other Tech
Giants over the last week or so
I mean when you look at big pack I mean
big pack has really been a shining star
in this market and I think it's further
and further almost the safety sector for
investors big tax cut and cost but yet
demands holding up better than feared I
think that's why you know especially
after these numbers you're going to see
more and more investors focused on these
stocks I still think tech stocks have
another 10 to 15 upside the rest of the
year and you walk away just further
confident from Apple to Google to Amazon
to Microsoft in terms of what we're
seeing overall demand one very
interesting point of difference between
Apple and some of its peers is that
while the likes of alphabets meta have
been laying off employees Amazon as well
Apple hasn't why not
why do those peers I mean they were
spending money like 1980s rock stars uh
during the pandemic uh
I mean they they hired
so there's the likes of meta Google and
others and that's why they're in much
more of a position to to sort of cut
costs around the edges but also
aggressively spending AI in some other
areas it also just speaks to you know
cook continues to sort of be that Hall
of Fame CEO navigating Apple through
this and actually gaining share at the
same time
Dan you talked earlier on about the
replacement cycle and how potentially
that uh supports Apple's earnings in in
coming uh months but uh what about
pricing did we hear anything from Tim
Cook on that last night
yeah I mean they talked about what I
would call you know very stable pricing
I think what they're not talking about I
mean we think the average selling price
is actually ahead of 900 925 dollars to
give you some perspective about a year
and a half because that was 800 so
you're starting to see more and more
consumers go for higher end phones
that's giving them a further Talent more
margin leverage and ultimately that's
why In This Storm that they're actually
having significant talwinds you know
from consumers globally especially in
China which continues to be key
ingredient in their success
now the share price last night closed at
around 166 dollars I suspect I know what
your answer will be but I'll put it to
you anyway I think you've got a 12 month
Target of 205 dollars well the risks to
that forecast on the downside or the
upside
oh I think this is a stock that goes
higher from here I didn't know there was
some nervousness and sort of White
Knuckles going into the Sprint and I
think Cupertino yet again flexed their
muscles I think there's a stock on its
way to 200 you know based on what we see
in terms of demand especially in this
market
all right Dan gotta leave it there
thanks again for joining me so early
today and uh staying with us thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and shares of International Airlines
group the owner of British Airways now
Lingus have risen by two and three
quarter percent this morning after the
company said profits for the year would
be better than expected iag said that
leaving off one of cot I one of items it
made an operating profit of 9 million
euros for the first three months of the
year that compared with a loss of 741
million euros during the same period
last year and was the first time since
2019 that the company had traded
profitably during the quarter Luis
Gallego iag's chief executive said
particularly strong demand in Spain and
Latin America as well as on routes to
the USA had helped Iberia to its best
ever first quarter performance and made
it one of the world's most profitable
Airlines During the period he said ba
has also traded profitably during the
quarter for the first time since 2019.
the safety environmental and Healthcare
Services Group homase buying a business
whose technology repairs and
rehabilitates Wastewater pipelines
without the need to dig a trench the
ftse 100 company is paying 41 million
euros for sewertronics a pipe renovation
Solutions business based in the Polish
capital of Warsaw with further payments
of up to 18 million euros potentially
falling due dependent on performance or
Mark Ron Shetty home as chief executive
said sewertronics growth would be driven
by the increasing need to repair aging
Wastewater infrastructure and reduce
Wastewater links
and InterContinental Hotels group said
this morning that its chief executive
Keith Barr would be stepping down at the
end of June after five years in the job
Mr Barr who's been at the company for
more than 30 years and who steered the
business through the pandemic will be
replaced by Ellie Malouf who's been
running ihg's America's business for the
last eight years well the news came as
IHG whose Brands include Holiday Inn
Hotel Indigo and Crowne Plaza reported
that its revenue for available room
which is a key industry metric Rose by
33 during the first three months of the
year
yeah
well last night's banking LED sell-off
on Wall Street was followed by mixed
trading overnight in the Asia Pacific
region as the picture you can ignore the
uh Nikkei in the top left hand corner
that is closed for third consecutive day
as part of the golden week celebrations
well in Europe stocks are largely in
positive territory this morning there
you go all the main Continental European
indices in positive territory right now
talking points this morning include
Adidas Shares are ahead by five and
three quarter percent in Frankfurt
falling better than expected quarterly
results well here in London the ftse 100
is also in positive territory currently
a third of one percent higher on gains
for their oil and Mining heavyweights
the leading Blue Chip gain their own
percentage terms is IHG which I
mentioned a moment ago on the downside
the medical equipment supply converter
it Shares are offered by just under one
percent the chief executive has been
selling stock there to pay for a tax
bill that's a weighed on the share price
I think otherwise there are not too many
features in the ftse this morning for
investors to hang their hats on outside
the a footsie with the leading mid cap
Gainer right now is wizer the shares are
up by uh nearly three percent that is in
sympathy with iag which you can see is
up just under three percent right now on
the downside virgin money is another one
and a half percent lower that's on the
back of the drop in profits that uh it
reported yesterday no down the corporate
food chain interesting one to mention
the consultancy TPX impact the shares
there up some 10 and that is on news
that results this year will be better
than expected on the Foreign Exchange
Market very interesting uh session
yesterday Sterling rallied against the
Euro after the European Central Bank
slowed the pace of its interest rate
Rises as you can see the pound currently
up a tenth of one percent Against The
single currency it's up by quarter of
one percent right now against the
Greenback the Euro meanwhile is ahead by
six and one percent against the dollar
as for the oil price well that is on
course for its third weekly fall in four
weeks although it's rallied this morning
about a breakthrough will currently set
you back
73.58 a barrel that is up one and a half
percent on the session joining me today
is Neil Wilson he's Chief Market Analyst
at finale good to see you this morning
I'm in the the big story all week has
been uh central banks where are we at
the end of all that do you think
uh yeah I mean we've had the Federal
Reserve and the European central banks
in action and uh you know the the Fed
was
um always gonna signal uh a pause uh
that's and that's kind of what the
market uh had been expecting kind of
pricing
um but I think it was interesting it was
probably it was you know the fed's job
on Wednesday was really not to Signal
the pause but to to leave the door open
to actually continue hiking rates I know
that sort of seems a bit contrary to the
sort of consensus that view that we're
that we're hearing but
um the the I think the third is still in
inflation busting mode and I think you
know the data in the US is still holding
up
um they are waiting to see what sort of
credit tightening happens from the from
the banking crisis I think those bound
to be credit tightening
um but I think that the FED is it
doesn't want to it doesn't want to say
for sure that it's going to pause in
June it wants to at least leave that
door open that the market though is
going off in a in a totally different
direction the Market's pricing in Cuts I
think a 60 chance that the FED actually
Cuts in July
um again just seems completely odds with
what the FED is saying geopol very very
uh stringent in in in in his sort of
view that that there wouldn't be any
Cuts coming
um this year
um so I think the FED is going to be
tighter for longer than the market is
currently pricing that has implications
obviously for uh for the indices for for
Bond markets and where we go for for the
broader Market from here I think the ECB
it sounded maybe sounded a little bit
dovish and it only raised rates by 25
basis points and we had sort of talked
about maybe doing 50
um but they did signal that they're
probably going to do more that inflation
is too high
um so I think I think the the sort of
the long and the short is that we're
still we're still in a position where
the major central banks are at least a
Fed in the ECB are are data dependent
they're they're looking they're watching
to see what's going on and they're going
to respond accordingly
um the the market seems to be saying
that the ECB is going to be going for a
bit longer in the hiking cycle and the
fed and the fed's going to start cutting
before the ECB does the ECB does
um but we're getting sort of mixed
messages on the data front as well so
German Factory or German today down 10
for example just sort of
um the difficulty the the the central
banks have they really do I mean if I
look at the FX markets Neil and the way
Sterling is trading against the dollar
in the Euro at the moment I mean clearly
there is a view a foot there that the
bank of England is going to carry on
raising even if the ECB and the Federer
on pause right now
yeah I think um you know Sterling's kind
of picked up some bed really on of the
back of the fact that the economy is not
doing as badly as we thought
um we seem to be avoiding that that big
you know big sort of recession at the
moment and the PMI data earlier this
week
um has been sold the construction data
today solid hit the services PMI data
earlier in the week solid
um but also pointing to inflationary
pressure is re-emerging and that's that
again just sort of underlines the
problems the the sort of central dilemma
facing the central banks which is
um you know as soon as you as soon as
you you see the economy pick up
um the the inflation engineer comes out
the bottle again and so they have to to
press down on the on the brakes again
with it with with more rate hikes so
they're they're in a in a pretty tough
situation right now but it does look
like Sterling can can maybe make some
further games
um and it does look like the dollar in
could be could be facing a tough ride if
the market starts to to see the fact
cutting I think the the chances though
are that the FED actually doesn't cut I
think I I would go with what G Pals
saying
um they're not going to cut this year
and that that could see the dollar uh
maybe rebound a bit uh later in the year
absolutely well if they do you know
Christmas shopping in New York again for
the first time in a few years Neil gonna
leave it there good to see you this
morning
thanks a lot
still to come here on Ian King live my
Mastercard is moving into payment
technology with a new tech Hub in Dublin
don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back now Payments Technology is
currently one of the hottest parts of
the financial services sector presenting
both an opportunity and a threat for
established players like MasterCard the
company the 17th largest in the S P 500
is seeking to reposition itself from a
payment processing Corporation to
broader Payments Technology business and
to that end it's just opened a tech Hub
in Dublin where it expects to employ
some 2 000 people by 2025. I've been
speaking with Ed McLaughlin he's
mastercard's Chief technology officer
and began by asking him why the company
had chosen Dublin
in some ways I think Dublin chose us
we've been in Ireland for 15 years now
and it started with a relatively small
company to joined MasterCard I think
there's 36 people at the time and since
then we've grown to over 1300 and we'll
continue to uh we continue to invest and
grow from there it's just been a
fabulous location for us it gives us
full access to Europe the talent we've
been able to see the engineering that's
come out of the Dublin Tech Hub has been
fantastic
it feels as though the pace of
technological change is really
intensifying right now what does that
mean for a business like MasterCard
it is a tremendous time to be a
technologist and when we look at what
we're able to do with machine learning
with generative AI with the powerful new
techniques with the network fabric we're
putting in place using both private and
public Cloud technology I think the
amount of capability that we can bring
to bear to solve problems for customers
and Merchants and help create
sustainable Economic Development it's in
my career an unprecedented time for the
the scope and the capabilities that are
now available to us you mentioned
generative AI there what kind of
applications could it have
uh all sorts of if you think about what
the large language models are doing it's
great for for predictions so people have
lots of questions and if we train it on
the right data sets and make sure that
we have the right Providence of the
information you can use this really
powerful technique to interact with
consumers to give better instruction and
documentation to people who want to
develop applications against our Network
so we see it as a way of expanding a
knowledge base and making it much more
accessible for the MasterCard
information
you're obviously more broadly trying to
evolve from being just a payments
company to being a technology company
how difficult is that when you have a
legacy business to protect
well I would say that business we've
always run from MasterCard has always
been based on technology we've been a
long leader in things like Edge
Computing the way we apply AI to prevent
fraud in the network and to secure the
network for that so when I think about
the the physical cards that was just an
access token we had to give to people to
get onto the network I don't think
anyone benefits more than MasterCard
from getting out of the physical world
and having all the new digital
connectivity that we have so as the
network of the platform we've always
used technology to connect to our
partners to enable the transactions to
flow and to add all the value-added
services that we can to that
I just wonder with so much going on how
do you decide what to make a priority
off these days
well it's easy you work back from your
customer
so when we look at what the customers
are looking for richer experiences that
we can embed in the digital devices that
they're using how through things like
Financial inclusion we can bring more
customers onto the network if you look
at Merchants we're now up to a hundred
million Merchants that are connected to
the MasterCard Network and that's
doubled in just the last five years so
we look at what technologies enable what
our customers want to do and then we
make sure we're bringing it to them
through the network
obviously The Internet of Things is
another Hot Topic you've spoken in the
past about uh the fact that you think a
lot more devices in in future are going
to be available to make payments with
what does that mean for the traditional
piece of plastic in your wallet will
that still be around in 10 15 years time
well two things I I think every
connected device we have in some way
will be used for Commerce the
experiences we can have the embedding of
Commerce whether it's your mobile or
your car or Advanced virtual reality
sets all of those things people want to
use to interact and transact so we're
enabling those in the MasterCard Network
as far as the card itself you got
something that works great that a lot of
people like so it gets back to the
consumer I think we'll support card
based payments as long as people want
them and as long as it's useful for
merchants one thing that often crops up
when you talk about iot with people is
it potentially opens the door it's more
opportunities for hacking if you like
how do you keep on top of that threat
yeah security is ever more important so
looking at things like zero trust
networks where every transaction is
signed the way we're using encryption
Technologies to make sure that we can
secure each individual transaction one
great example is what we've done with
our tokenization system that allows you
to create a digital version of your
MasterCard put it in any device that
digital version is unique to that device
so it could ever be copied or reused and
every transaction coming off of it the
individual sign so it can't be replayed
so we always know where it's coming from
so security is our first thought when
we're enabling any of these new
experiences
will the ability to make payments as it
becomes more ubiquitous does that
potentially over time erode the the
power of people like Apple and Samsung
well I I think it's when we talk about
embedded Commerce right people work
across multiple ecosystems so you have
your Digital streaming account with
Netflix you'll have high loyalty with
the merchant like Starbucks you'll have
an apple or a Samsung device you'll have
uh Mercedes or a General Motors vehicle
um you'll have a a Chromebook or a Dell
computer so for us it's giving consumers
that consistent access across any of the
environments they have and really what
we do with MasterCards we give you
access back to your accounts from any of
those ecosystems that are out there so I
think people will participate more and
more in these very very rich very very
immersive environments and what they
want from us is make sure it all works
together back with the accounts you
already have
that was Ed McLaughlin from MasterCard
now dating back to the 1300s hallmarking
is just about the oldest form of
consumer protection the first home of
hallmarking in the UK was the London
assay office at the goldsmiths company
one of the city of London's 12 great
Livery companies and to celebrate the
coronation the goldsmiths company has
produced a limited edition coronation
Hallmark I dropped in to take a look
King Charles III is already making his
mark on Britain but here at the
goldsmiths company one of Europe's
oldest precious metal authenticators
it's more literal
hallmarking is a legal requirement for
the sale of precious metals in the UK
and it's a regulation that dates back
centuries but this year Goldsmith is
doing something a little bit different
continuing a tradition begun in 1934
with the Silver Jubilee of King George V
and Queen Mary goldsmiths are
authenticating gold and silver submitted
to them with a new coronation Hallmark
hallmarking is Britain's oldest
continuous form of consumer protection
and it goes all the way back to the year
1300 so this is the time that the First
hallmarking Act is passed and the idea
then is to make sure that on scrupulous
goldsmiths don't sell items pieces of
jewelry maybe you know Cutlery to the
public that has got too much base metal
mixed in because for most people if you
just look at an item it looks gold or it
looks silver but you can't really tell
quite how pure it is
2022 was an exceptionally busy year for
the London assay office with the late
Queen's Platinum Jubilee but this year
is turning out to be just as busy tens
of thousands of pieces of gold and
silver hallmarked with the king's
moniker have already passed through
these doors and if you've ever wondered
where the term Hallmark comes from it's
from this very Hall pieces have been
authenticated here since the 1300s it's
an institution almost as old as the
monarchy itself
the process used to involve the new
stamp of approval had to be sanctioned
by the British hallmarking Council and
can be applied by Punch or laser
the coronation Hallmark is available to
Jewelers silversmiths and retailers up
until the end of next year
when you're applying the mark you want
this line touching your thumb that's the
one that faces towards you
methods of hallmarking have modernized
with time with much of the stamping now
Happening by laser engraving however the
old ways are still being used thousands
of times a day sometimes we have to
place it back in again to make sure it's
uh at the right depth all the way around
getting all the detail out so that it's
a pristine Hallmark at the end for the
consumer to look at it and verify that
it's silver but obviously this is the
coronation Mark to indicate it was
Hallmark this year even though
goldsmiths has been around longer than
Buckingham Palace the Guild Hall and
even the bank of England practices have
changed since the company's Inception in
1327. we've invested heavily in x-ray
testing equipment and lasers for
hallmarking that allow us to process
items extremely quickly and minimizing
that disruption to the supply chain all
the Glitters isn't gold but this
coronation has all the Hallmarks of a
historic occasion
now not long ago the area around
London's King's cross and Saint Pancras
Railway stations now home to the
Eurostar Terminus was a no-go Zone but
it's undergone a stunning regeneration
during the last two decades Central to
which was the eight-year restoration of
Sir Gilbert George Gilbert Scott's grade
one listed Gothic Masterpiece the former
Midland Grand hotel now the saint
Pancras Renaissance Hotel well that
building is 150 years old today I've
been speaking with Harry handlesman the
hotelier and developer who drove its
restoration
I think 150 years is important for
anybody
and what it is it's sort of a milestone
and more importantly what it does do it
allows or it makes people really reflect
that in 1873 this amazing building was
erected one of the grandest hotels in
the world that came to being and of
course in the United Kingdom Great
Britain which I think really reflects
when you look at the star and you look
at everything else it sort of looked at
about the future about the ambition what
people want to do in terms of the
Midland the Midland Railways so uh
having that now having that in the 21st
century where we have
always all the progresses that has been
made in any from transport and
everything else
I think it gives people the opportunity
to reflect it will be people the
opportunity to kind of think you know
let's look at the past look look what to
do and perhaps it will become a kind of
uh an ambition for the future by looking
at this building it was obviously home
for many years by British Rail failing
to disrepair and generations of London
has walked or droved or cycled past it
and in despair looking at how this
fantastic building had had gone into
decline it's been a real labor of love
for you hasn't it it has been a labor of
love but you and a labor of love by
definition is you intend to spend so
much money and you double the budget
which is what happened over here all bit
all the research we did beforehand
thinking we really had a Down Part how
much the budget just accelerated but
what kept me going and it was really
staring at their base you know to the
tune that I had to you know the time as
a three-year-old I sort of had to empty
her piggy bank you know in in order to
continue working but that was what I
realized is I owe it to Gilbert Scott I
feel
undertaking work like that you owe it to
the city and I cared and I really wanted
to create something magnificent so we
did a further in Canada Incarnation and
over the years now that we've been open
since 2011 we're going through the new
one and we just opened the most Splendid
room in London which is the Midland
grand dining room which is actually
called after the original dining room
that was opened in 1873 and it's equally
Splendid the food is probably far better
today but it's got the French cuisine
element and adjacent era we have a
Gothic bar which is incredibly beautiful
so you know there's a sense of Pride
there's a threat of accomplishment
there's also not just an accomplishment
I know it's a way of getting Revenue
it's sort of
I'm privileged enough to be able to
contribute something to London with this
building and I think there's an
importance in that especially being in
the cultural quarters of London
obviously the hospitality industries had
a very very difficult time during the
pandemic and the aftermath do you feel
that you have to go that little bit
further now that demand is bouncing back
I think to me you always had to go I
mean to me Hospitality by definition you
have to be hospitable that's really what
it's all about for me it isn't just a
question of how much can I charge you
but how can I make you stay excellent
excited and everything else now it's
luckily I've got some amazing people
walking alongside with me that enable me
to do that so I don't necessarily look
at the bottom line and I'm lucky enough
that you know it's it's a Family Trust
so I don't require I don't have
shareholders telling me Harry I'd like
to have a bit more earnings on this I'm
able to indulge in my passion which is
great great buildings great places Great
Gatherings and I believe that what is
gorgeous and what is wonderful about a
hotel is you know when people come and
stay even one a night or two nights
they take ownership of their space you
know and I'm able to offer a lot of
people ownership in a great building and
that's a privilege
I mean attempts at regeneration don't
always work what for you the ingredients
that have to be in place for a
regeneration to really succeed well I I
met a very successful uh Banker who buys
properties that have challenges and he
came in here and he looked at himself
you know what Harry
I understand the attraction and 96 of
people are Doodles they invest the money
and they fail so I think it's
perseverance it's passion and it's
really understanding the product
creating something that is amazing
because at the end of the day if you do
submit as fabulous
people will come to a people respond to
it in a positive way and that's just a
reality if you create something that is
mediocre you have other things that are
more outstanding so you really have
competition here I feel I have no
competition not because of me because of
the Midland Rail and Gilbert Scott who
created this fantastic building but is
it becoming more difficult in a city
like London to identify the appropriate
opportunities for regeneration
think it is I think I think
you know London is and today there's
less is obvious because there's there's
so much Capital around it there's been
so much so many refurbishments and
development that have had more new
development so it is a little bit
difficult so what I do is for example
one of my uh nude my new uh development
that I'm planning on doing is a
relatively modest building about five
thousand fifty thousand square feet in
on Cotton road now I have a company
called Manhattan Love Corporation
curtain Road Hackney
Lofts how cool is that let's go back to
basics let's just create this again
the sale should go because people
there's a desire but actually I'm not
doing it I'm not doing Lofts I'm gonna
do a super cool commercial building
because what I believe despite having
amazing buildings cool exciting creative
fabulous Office Buildings in Cotton Road
shortage
I haven't seen many so let me introduce
something that might not be commercially
the most obvious thing to do but let's
try to do it and once you do it
hopefully I really do hope people will
appreciate and will people recognize you
know what we love Curtner road we don't
want to be in something modern we don't
want to do something where perhaps
people cut Corners we want to be in
something that's spectacular or that's
got feel that's got taste that's got
um um how do you say it's got service
Spirit behind it and and so those are
burning so I'm looking for my own little
niche that luckily my family is is
indulgent with me and they allow me my
idiosyncrasies
[Music]
time now for a lookout this morning's
business pages and the financial times
leads its print edition with yesterday's
interest rate rise from the European
Central Bank the paper's leader column
argued it with the U.S federal reserve
signaling it will pause on further
increases this week and the ECB
moderating the pace at which it is
raising rates the rate Rising cycle is
moving into its final stages the Ft also
carries on its front page a call from
Nelson Peltz the corporate Raider for
Deposit Insurance in the US to be raised
above a quarter of a million dollars in
order to save the regional lenders well
the times leads its business pages with
yesterday's slide in the shares of U.S
Regional lenders but it also carries on
its business front page a story first
broken by Sky's Mark clyman yesterday
that legal in general has put hundreds
of jobs at risk with the closure of its
modular homes Factory in Selby in West
Yorkshire well the Daily Telegraph also
leads with U.S banks but on its business
front page it also reports on comments
from Shell's new chief executive while
Sawan in which he warned that increased
windfold taxes on the oil and gas sector
would risk hurting investment in the
sector the existing taxes on North Sea
stand at 75 percent we're joining us
ever on a Friday morning is the
financial markets commentator and
evening standard Economist Neil Collins
Neil good to see you this morning let's
start with shell um they actually beat
expectations but you're still pretty
ticked off with them
yeah I don't think they've played the
hand they've had very well in the last
few years uh at the when the oil price
plunged it seems an age ago now they
panicked and they slashed the dividend
which had not been not fallen for over
half a century so if anything that was
reliable I think it was the shell
dividend that they clearly had a
boardroom panic and they slashed it down
and they've had two changes of dividend
policy since and at the moment they seem
to be spending more effort on buying in
their own shares than they are looking
after long-term shareholders
um they their current policy uh to raise
the dividend by four percent a year a
compound means that it won't be until
2032 before they get back to the level
that it was in 2020
and they just seem to have lost contact
with the idea that this is a very sound
stable business which can can afford to
pay dividends through good years and bad
and as a result of that their share
rating is embarrassingly lower than that
of Exxon which is their nearest
competitor in the US and I think this is
important and I don't think the borders
grasped this yet
Neil let's talk about the the banking
search obviously we hope we saw these
huge sell-offs in the United States
yesterday your column today makes the
point we're not seeing anything like
that here in the UK or in Europe why do
you think that is are all banks just
better capitalized
it's a bit of a mystery but I think that
the the structure of the banking
industry in the UK particularly is very
different to that in in the US
um
the big banks for a variety of reasons
are now almost like building societies
the vast amount of their lending is for
domestic mortgages uh which uh they have
been pushed into it by the last round of
banking regulations uh because the
following the last financial crisis
because domestic banking for advances
for mortgages were considered Ultra safe
and so that's where the money is gone
um and because they didn't have to
provide reserves against it but
um I suspect that underlying that is
because mortgages are so important and
such a big part of their business and
our lives if there was a possibility of
a serious problem in the mortgage Market
the UK government would step in and
taxpayer would get the bill so I think
that also helps to reassure uh the
depositors the other thing is of course
that the guarantee up to 85 000 pounds
for deposits means that the
vast spread of smaller I use the word
relatively
Savers are essentially protected by the
government guarantee anyway so I don't
see the same ingredients here for the
sort of panics that we've seen in the US
I wouldn't buy the shares mind you
because they always are risky things
Bank shares but I don't see that the uh
I don't think it's as contagious as some
people think okay Neil there you go
we've got to leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you
that's it from me we're back at 10
o'clock on Tuesday morning enjoy the
coronation next up it's Sophie Ridge
with an election result special one
should be joined by a political editor
Beth Rigby cheerio
[Music]